hello everyone
thank you so much for tuning in my name
is manoj gunty i'm the product marketing
manager for google cloud's
apigee api management platform and today
i'm joined by mudhik power
from t-mobile hi mudit
thank you manoj hello everyone my name
is mudi purvar
and i'm a principal engineer in api
center for enablement
leading the api devops engineering team
along with driving the ci cd
and self-service automation tools
initiatives or api program at t-mobile
welcome mudit so in this session we want
to explain
and show you a live demo of how you can
extend
google's industry leading ai and ml
technologies
to your api programs
for many years we had the opportunity to
work with customers
across the globe and across industries
throughout this journey we have observed
that the role of apis
and api management has been continuously
evolving
what used to be just an agent for
accessing various systems
is now actually an agent for driving
digital transformation programs
while apis continue to be built and
consumed by developers
it leadership marketing and other line
of business owners have started looking
at apis
as something beyond just a piece of
technology
to drive real digital transformation
programs
and when you align apis with your
digital experiences
it also creates an upstream impact on
the value chain
when your core business critical
applications are powered by apis
imagine what impact down times
performance degradations or even
security incidents
can have on your customers and partners
therefore api operations becomes
extremely critical to ensure
a connected and seamless digital
experience
is delivered to all the stakeholders
however operations teams are under
immense pressure
as a cis admin how do i ensure my apis
are
up and running and performing as
expected
when there is an issue how do i quickly
identify the root cause
and i want to do all of this without
getting distracted
by false alert noise as a sec
ops person i want to ensure my apis
adhere to compliance requirements i want
to protect my sensitive data from abuse
and quickly diagnose security incidents
and the good news is as you build and
scale your api programs
there's a goldmine of api data that's
collected
across the entire api value chain all
the way from your backend targets
to the front-end apps and this data can
be leveraged to solve
these problems google cloud's apigee api
management platform
applies industry-leading ai and ml
models
to harness the power of your data with
features like api monitoring
anomaly detection security reporting and
bot protection
you can now ensure that your apis are
always
available secure and performing as
expected
with that let me turn it over to mudit
to talk about
t-mobile's api journey and how they have
put
ai and ml powered capabilities into
practice
over to your mother thank you manoj
we at t-mobile are on a journey to
change the wireless experience of
our customers in today's digital age of
mobile web
artificial intelligence machine learning
internet of things
changing the customer experience is
impossible without leveraging the power
of apis across the digital value chain
hence let's reflect back on our api
journey so far
we started with apigee api gateway back
in 2015
with two dedicated api teams developing
apis to expose
legacy services for a new radically
simplified
frontline application in 2017
to bring some cohesiveness among the
growing api teams
proxygen a homegrown api development
tool was launched
it would take the api contract or the
swagger as an input
and generate the apigee api proxy bundle
check the code into the source code
management repository launch the ci cd
pipelines and deploy the apigee epa
proxy into apigee edge
it was an instant hit with the api
developer community at t-mobile
api center for enablement was launched
in 2018
to address the growing challenges with
the api program
that was gradually emerging same sameel
we launched
a suite of api first development tools
to enable the domain teams
to self-serve themselves for any need on
the apigee api platform
and here we are in 2020 with 80 plus
business domain teams
developing apis within t-mobile together
they have produced 1300 plus api proxies
resulting in over 9 billion transactions
per month
let's look at some of the api
operational challenges that come with
this kind of growth
here are some of the challenges we
continually face every day
in the api operations space and some of
these
might resonate with your company's api
operations as well
securing and protecting apis from
external and internal bad actors
bot traffic denial of service attacks
broken authentication and so so on and
so forth
and trying to continually maintain a
secure posture to have a seamless
digital experience of for our customers
observability into unexpected and
unforeseen api
runtime issues and contextual
information about those issues
is a key challenge to improve the api
availability and performance
api platform scalability to handle the
certain traffic burst
during our uncarrier move announcements
like our latest uncarrier move
scam shield and promotional events like
black friday
holiday season etc on a similar note
capacity planning to support new
innovative growth
that we foresee beyond wireless like our
banking service t-mobile
money our tv service t-vision and others
and then streamlining the api consumer
and partner onboarding process to access
t-mobile apis
to improve the api consumer and partner
experience and agility
ai and ml have definitely helped us in
addressing some of these challenges
ai and ml features like api monitoring
and
apigee sense have definitely empowered
our everyday api operations
by covering our blind side for
unforeseen api traffic and performance
issues
which could go undetected and cause
severe api availability incidents
and impact the business negatively
anomaly detection in api operations by
applying ai
and ml models is aligned with t-mobile's
observability objectives
like proactively monitoring the systems
and apis
detecting issues prior to any negative
impact on the business
and developing auto healing capabilities
where possible
alerting and notification combined with
anomaly detection
for real time traffic and performance
issues
has improved our team's productivity and
significantly reduced the mttd
meantime to diagnose api incidents
with the added suggested operator
controls in the form of predetermined
resolution playbooks
for any issues has notably reduced the
mttr
mean time to resolution of any api
incident
let's look at a demo on how ai and ml
have empowered our api operations at
t-mobile
let's check out some of the rpgs
built-in ai and ml features in real time
and how these features are assisting in
keeping t-mobile apis available
and performant for a seamless digital
experience of t-mobile customers
when you log into apigee edge this is
how the landing page looks like
you can get to all the observability
related features
under the analyze tab
as a devops engineer i visit the api
monitoring overview dashboard
quite frequently this dashboard provides
me with a quick summary
about the runtime telemetry of all the
api proxies deployed in the production
environment
for the purposes of this demo we will be
using one of our development
environments
wherein hopefully you will not see a lot
of broken stuff
as you can see in this dashboard we get
a summary information about a given api
environment
total traffic in transactions per second
overall average error rate percentage
top api proxy response p99 latency value
and total number of recent alerts
it also provides top three api proxies
with highest value
in each metric category
so this dashboard provides a devops
engineer a pretty good
overview of any potential runtime issues
with any api proxy
now let's move on to the events tab to
check if there have been any recent
alerts triggered or any new anomalies
detected
looks like we will have to go a little
bit back in time to see any alerts and
anomaly
there you go so the alert tab shows
all the recent triggered alerts based on
the predefined conditions set by us
the anomaly tab shows all the events
that deviate
from the normal behavioral pattern at
the apogee
region organization and environment
level
these deviations as well as their
severity
is detected by applying the built-in ai
and
ml models to the historical api data
the cool thing about the anomaly is the
contextual
information it provides with respect to
environment name api proxy name target
fall code region and the time of the
trigger
for a devops engineer this contextual
information about an anomaly is really
critical
and important as it significantly
reduces
the overall mttd mean time to diagnose
and mttr mean time to resolution
for any unexpected and unforeseen issues
within our apis which might be in our
blind side
and the amazing thing about this feature
is that
we do not have to do anything to set all
this up
it comes by default and is is built in
so based on this contextual information
if a devops engineer decides to dive in
deeper into the anomaly
he or she can drill down into the
anomaly
and it will take them into the
investigate page
or the tab so let's investigate one of
the anomalies
just looking at the anomaly details on
the top looks like
this anomaly was detected due to a
reasonably high number of
504 response code in the api flow
which started at around 3 17 in the
afternoon
let's look at why the api is returning
the 504 error response to the clients
now i have various ways and different
dimensions that i can find the root
cause about this issue
let's try to determine the fault source
in the api flow
by looking at uh different dimensions
i would want to look at the fault source
at this point in time
so i'll go select that dimension from
the drop down
and as we can see in the api flow
it is pretty obvious that the target
endpoint is the problematic area
so let's dig in further by clicking on
the target cell
here we can see the suspected cars
determined by
the ml model which can be attributed to
the fault code
which clearly states that the error
response code is being written by the
backend service
also there are details for the impacted
clients ap clients and the target
endpoints that this api is dependent
upon and is at fault for this anomaly
now if we want to look at any specific
transaction level information
we can do so by going into view logs
this view provides us
into specific details about each
transaction
like the request uri which is basically
the
uri being invoked by the api client
along with the request message id
what is the status code response time
fault source
and other details about the client and
the transaction
next i can do additional things with
this anomaly like
creating an alert based off this anomaly
so let's quickly create an alert based
off this anomaly
we'll have to hit this button create
alert tab
and we'll have to come up with the alert
name uh
of our choice provide the description to
it
um what type of alert if we want to base
this alert based off this anomaly we can
leave it at anomaly
and then alter the condition if we
choose to
or let it remain the same as detected by
the anomaly
then we have to select the alert
notification type we want
like email notification or slack or a
page of duty notification
once we have filled out this form we
just have to save this
and we have a pre-configured alert for a
given anomaly condition
for future proactive uh notifications
so let me share some sample alert
notifications
here is one email alert notification and
how it looks like
it provides us information like the
timestamp of the trigger
org name alert name
summary of the alert and details
regarding the alerts like the condition
trigger value proxy region etc
and it also provides embedded links to
directly view the event in apigee edge
this is how a sample slack notification
looks like
it provides us the name of the alert
organization name
threshold violation details like um
the target latency proxy name region
condition information uh so on and so
forth
uh it also provides us web links
as well to view the anomaly or the alert
details directly into
the events tab of apigee edge
so let's go back
now i can do uh further things like i
can create
a report based off this anomaly to look
for any additional dimensions for the
further analysis or for an rca or for
management reporting needs
we are really impressed by the api
monitoring feature
as it has helped mitigate latency and
network issues
in the past resulting in increased api
availability along with improved
performance of our apis
next let's see how collections can be
really useful
in making the most out of these ai nml
features
collections are group of api proxies
targets
developer apps based on the
organization's choice of dimension
we at tmobile have collections based off
business domain apis
which helps us in setting up appropriate
alert
configurations and threshold values
for the same group of apis
next i want to move on to security
security is one of the single biggest
challenge that most of the digital
enterprises are trying to solve
and it never gets easier with ever
evolving
newer threats surfacing every day
in the security reporting overview
dashboard we have information with
respect to
northbound api traffic for all the given
environments
and it tells us provides further
information
regarding the api proxies taking active
traffic out of the total api is deployed
uh total number of shade flows deployed
in a given environment
total traffic and the percentage change
in traffic
it also provides the api client traffic
composition by region
since this is one of our development
environment
and most of our developers are based in
u.s
west coast hence we can see the
corresponding traffic composition being
higher
in the u.s west region let's move on to
the runtime dashboard
which provides us more specific and
detailed runtime information about the
api proxies
it provides information about the api
proxy traffic
percentage change in traffic and
percentage of traffic
on non-https or non-secured port
and the total number of api clients
invoking or accessing this api
and if i want to uh look for the details
into api proxy
it provides us a visualized graph for
the https and non-https
uh api access protocols
and then it also provides further data
points with respect to developer apps
virtual hosts and target endpoints that
this api proxy is
dependent on uh let's move on to the
configuration
of the api proxies
this particular dashboard provides us
insight into the api proxy's
security configuration and policy
composition
uh as well as providing information
about the virtual host definitions as
well
so different categories of policies
include the traffic management security
and extension policies
uh and all as well as reusable piece of
code in the form of shared flows
so uh virtual host uh is a definition
in api proxy which determines how the
api clients
uh or on which protocol the apic clients
are going to access the apis
if we want to dig deeper into specific
security policy details
uh that are part of api proxy we can
click on api proxy
and we can see specific policy
names that are part of this given api
proxy
and then if there are some security
policy standards that have been
established by our apa program
we can evaluate each and every proxy
against those standards
to see whether these apis are com in
compliance or not
so this dashboard is very helpful in a
quick glance on the security posture
of our runtime api configurations
so all of this data that is visualized
on this dashboard is also available via
apis for the security organization
uh to integrate this data with the
custom dashboards and reporting tools
finally we're going to talk about user
activity
as the user activity dashboard has
individual user identifying information
which i cannot display therefore i have
screenshots for
the user activity details dashboard
user activity dashboard provides insight
into user access
and their access behavior on the apigee
edge ui
or why are the management apis
and as well as change in user activity
over the period of time and
what type of data they are accessing and
percentage of potentially sensitive
operations they have performed if we
identify any suspicious
activity by a user we can drill down
further on all the activities and
actions performed by a particular user
like the resources they have accessed
and what action
they have taken on those particular
resources to recap
security reporting feature provides us
with relevant data points and matrix
to evaluate whether api proxies are
adhering to security policies
and configuration requirements set forth
by the organization's digital security
team
lastly realizing the value of these
productive ai
and ml features is the key to have
highly available and performant apis
for any api program next let's review
some real world business outcomes
wherein these features were immensely
valuable for our api devops engineering
team
bot traffic is estimated to be 40
percent of overall internet traffic
and out of those 20 is bad bot traffic
speaking of bad bot traffic one of the
anomalies we had was certain search in
traffic to our
auth api during off business hours which
is
odd upon diagnosing the issue
we found out that some bad actors
overseas were trying to harvest the
access tokens
from the auth api using bots
specifically bad bots
as this was a major security incident we
moved fast to remedy the issue
coupled with apigee sense and other raf
tools
we were able to successfully block the
bar traffic
very quickly next
network latencies can cause substantial
degradation in service and negatively
impact
the slas another anomaly detected was
network latency and api response times
apa transactions were making
coast-to-coast round trip
to our east coast data center even
though the traffic originated in u.s
west region
adding substantial latency and
negatively impacting our customers
digital web experience upon diagnosing
the issue
the major cloud provider unconsciously
made changes to their networking routing
logic
to elevate the issue though for entry we
made few routing logic changes in our
api flow
but ultimately the cloud provider was
able to permanently fix the network
issue
on their site new product launches
and new promotions like our latest and
carrier move are big events
and can bring huge certain traffic to
our websites
next anomaly detected was a certain
burst in api traffic for t-vision apis
when they were launched
we expected a surge but not the extent
of 700 increase
since this was one of the sas
environments
apogee support team at google was
contacted to check upon
auto-scale capabilities of the apigee
runtime components
to handle the additional load all of
these incidents were detected by api
monitoring
which is a testament to ai and ml
capabilities
for automated monitoring and alerting
along with the ability to dig deeper
into
an anomaly or incident in real time to
diagnose the issue and find resolution
for it
to conclude ai and ml have significantly
transformed the business of operating
apis
and in near future using advanced
predictive analytics
the ability to predict incidents before
they impact customer
and probably self-resolve will elevate
it to the next level
thank you and back to you manoj
that's awesome thank you everyone for
tuning in hope you have
got a good insight on how you can apply
ai and ml to your api programs
feel free to post any questions or
comments that you may have
in the q a module and we'll be more than
happy to address them
once again thank you so much for tuning
in and have a very nice day
you